merci à tous merci merci pour cette
bienvenus surprenant puis vous dire que
pour laurine riccione mois après onze
semaines
il est bon d'être avec vous ici chez
nous à calgary et nous voulons aussi
sûreté le pion à tous ceux qui sont ici
de la grande circonscription de calgary
a hérité du dans quelques moments mais
année j'aurai plus sans dire à ce niveau
mais tout d'abord je vais m'adresser au
pays parce que nous croyons que les
canadiens et canadiennes qui travaillent
devraient conserver plus de l'argent
qu'ils gagnent leurs éléments ils sont
entrés dans la vie publique parce que
nous croyons que les canadiens qui
travaillent fort de regarder beaucoup
plus tôt l'argent qu'ils gagnent parce
que nous croyons parce que nous croyons
que le gouvernement devrait gérer
l'argent des gens de la même façon que
les gens gèrent le leur parce que mes
amis nous nous vivons dans un monde
difficile le canada doit faire avancer
nos valeurs défendre nos intérêts et se
tenir avec nos amis
nous avons été les champions de ces
valeurs tout le long de notre vie
publique ministre ces dernières ne fane
et demi j'ai eu l'honneur incroyable de
servir comme votre premier ministre et
ça a été pour mon expérience remarquable
pour avoir rencontré les canadiens d'un
océan à l'autre et c'est à dire durant
cette campagne et nous regardons
absolument rien nous avons tout mis tout
ce que nous avions donné et nous ne
regrettons rien mes amis comment
pourrions-nous le regretter nous
demeurons toujours des citoyens du
meilleur pays au monde
mes amis notre pays est une des plus
vieilles démocraties au monde
aujourd'hui est pour aujourd'hui pour
quarante septième fois en plus d'un
siècle les canadiens ont choisi un
parlement et les résultats de ce soir
n'étaient pas ceux auxquels nous nous
attendions mais le peuple n'a jamais
tort résultats que nous acceptons sans
aucune hésitation que les liens avec sap
les canadiens ont élu un gouvernement
libéral et par conséquent nous allons
fêter ce résultat sans ces stations et
j'ai parlé mes amis un monsieur trudeau
et je lui offre toutes mes félicitations
pour les succès de sa campagne et je les
assurer de ma pleine et entière
collaboration durant le processus de
transition ces prochains jours
je veux aussi bien sûr félicité monsieur
moquer madame et monsieur duceppe pour
leur campagne à tous les canadiens de
toutes les parties du pays
je vous salue vos efforts ont aidé à
garder notre démocratie forte et au
comme étant de la circonscription de
kadri héritage suite merci merci pour
m'avoir renouveler votre soutien encore
une fois c'est le septième mandat que
vous me donnez et c'est un privilège que
de servir la population de cette soute
de cette ville des plus dynamiques au
canada mes amis il y a tellement de gens
qui méritent des félicitations pour leur
travail dans une campagne nationale et
bien sûr où il y a au début de cette
liste ma famille le rynbend riccio
je vous aime plus que vous ne pouvez
l'imaginer et bien sûr j'ai dû me
reposer sur vous non pas seulement ces
derniers soixante et dix neuf jours mais
depuis combien longtemps sans vous tout
cela eût été impossible mais avec
vous.tout l'était alors je vous remercie
mon équipe je vais aussi remercier notre
équipe de campagne partout au pays ce
qui est avec nous sur la route et nous
notre quartier général à ottawa et bien
sûr celui de qadri est au dessus de tous
les les quelques 300 circonscription
électorale de ce pays
notre parti mes amis est une
organisation qui a bien sûr les résineux
et nous sénégalais de ses bénévoles que
notre parti a pu répandre son message et
ce soir mes amis nous avons été à même
de faire élire une très forte opposition
officielle au parlement d'ottawa
pour tous ceux qui de cette dernière
décennie et demie on contribue à la
construction de notre pays nous qu'en
tant que vous avez toute notre gratitude
et vous ne pouvez qu'être fier nous non
seulement est ce que vous êtes déçu et
j'en suis responsable et j'en suis le
seul responsable mais la prochaine fois
ce parti va offrir aux canadiens une
alternative forte et claire basée sur
nos valeurs conservatrices ou et nous
allons souffrir cette partie qui a
établi une base solide et durable y
compris au québec
mes amis n'oubliez jamais n'oubliez
jamais que à cause de vos efforts votre
pays est très fort aujourd'hui et notre
le canada et or notre économie est en
croissance de 12 emplois sont créés le
budget s'équilibre et et les impôts
fédéraux sont oublie pas depuis quelque
50 et nous devrions aussi saisir
l'opportunité qui vient avec eux le
libre échange avec le pacifique et
l'atlantique le terrain nos gens dans
les forces armées ont les outils pour
accomplir leur boulot et nous nous
sommes tenus du côté de nos citoyens et
mes années dans un monde dangereux
nous avons été toujours en faveur de la
liberté de la démocratie d'affûter ça
c'est le canada que nous conservateur
avons bâti depuis l'époque de chuck et
mega man et si le canada que nous
souhaitons pour les générations à venir
et ou s'ils seront dédiés merci mes amis
merci à vous tous pour votre soutien
pour tout ce que vous avez fait pour
notre pays
et s'il vous plaît faites une petite
frayeur on aux hommes et nos femmes en
uniforme que dieu vous bénisse
steven a peu après 1,9 à et plusieurs
voies pour moi presque dix ans au
pouvoir qui a remodelé ce pays-là qui a
réduit la taille du pays qui a changé le
système de justice qui a changé
l'économie dans ce pays accueille des
politiques contre version
d'environnement si on en a peu qui dit
merci au revoir
en fait si le directeur du parti qui
nous annonce que je suis un peu lui a
demandé demain d'organiser une réunion
pour se choisir un chef intérimaire dans
ce caucus important de 103 députés
j'appelle qui a félicité le gagnant mais
qui quand même revenu messieurs dames et
c'est quand même un frappant au début de
son discours avec les taxes je tenais à
des taxes plus basse je tenais un pays
qui ne laisse pas tomber ses alliés
faisant référence à la mission contre
l'état islamique où vous le savez les
libéraux veulent cesser les
bombardements canadiens dont un sur un
peu qui continuait à appeler des d'une
certaine façon pour sa vision du pays
je n'ai pas de regret je n'ai pas de
regret dit-il
je pars la tête haute vous je vous
laisse une opposition avec 103 députés
une forte opposition à ottawa oui parce
que dans les détails mesdames et
messieurs rats déclaration conférence de
presse du président du parti
tous souhaitent annoncer à me suis un
peu qu'à voulu éviter d'en de se lancer
dans un adieux déchirants qui a été
plutôt était plutôt directe en disant
bon ben on a fait notre campagne on
tenait à certaines choses et on a perdu
je félicite notre nos adversaires tour
de table messieurs dames c'est pas
étonnant qu'il parte emmanuel non c'est
pas étonnant qu'il parte avec 103
députés la défaite on pourra absolument
pas imaginer monsieur rein peut
retourner dans l'opposition ce qu'il
avait à faire il le fait certains
diraient peut-être que c'est parce qu'il
y avait de la misère aussi à proposer
quelque chose de fondamentalement
nouveau
à offrir un nouveau projet aux canadiens
que cette campagne s'est révélée à terme
être aussi difficile
le kitchen c'est pas ça ne sera pas trop
plus beaux moments
voilà même de sa carrière les fautes non
plus moi ce que je remarque aussi c'est
que c'est un discours qui est un peu à
l'image de l'homme le politicien et de
sa campagne
on laisse un communiqué de presse
annoncé qu'il va démissionner on est
très protocolaire en surface finalement
alors que pour lui ce discours là quand
même quelques gouverné le pays pendant
les dix dernières années on peut l'aimer
une polémique mais il a transformé en
partie le canada alors qu'aujourd'hui ce
soir il a dit le minimum chez les roms
faut quand même un sonic dans
l'entourage de monsieur trudeau ont dit
que l'appel de monsieur harper que celui
ci s'est montré très très gracieux
lorsqu'il a concédé la victoire bonnot
l'îlot du suis juste être dos et que dès
demain donc on va demander à la
greffière du conseil privé le de mettre
en place la profonde